now um I I spent a long time in
Parliament as you know Muhammad and in
much of it uh the the air was full of
fear of the
radicalization as they always put it uh
of Muslims of Muslim youth uh they
feared that the Iraq War the Afghan war
the aftermath of both uh would uh shut
optic the level of radicalization and
the danger of young Muslims being lured
onto the rocks of separatism and
violence uh they had multi-million pound
programs uh prevent and so on uh which
uh weren't very successful but you knew
at least why they were doing these
things they had a legitimate fear of
radicalization I used to
say you know a Muslim watching on
television what's happening in Iraq
what's happening in
Afghanistan is likely to feel pretty
radical there's no need for a cleric uh
to wind them up there's no need for a
pamphlet uh to to Tool them they have
their their eyes they can see what's
happening to their
co-religionists so how radical are
Muslims around the world feeling right
now watching what's happening in
Gaza it's a really good question and I
think what's really interesting is that
you know AMA Bin Laden himself and
members of al-Qaeda and um you know all
the the associated kind of groups they
would use these kinds of atrocities
happening especially in Palestine as the
key way of recruiting other people I
mean the FAS that ama Bin Laden put
forward you will see and that's the
reason why it went viral um some weeks
ago in fact they were reading people
were reading the fetas because a a big
chunk of it was actually dedicated to
the Palestine issue now um if in terms
of what these uh particular groups uh
actually espouse what they espouse is
that if they kill our civilians this is
effectively a pragmatic kind of
consequentialist reasoning now they
think that this consequentialism uh this
Sharia consequentialism is acceptable
from an Islamic perspective which it
isn't because there's been a consensus
for 1,400 years on the matter and we can
we can quote the classical sources ABD
and others from the from the 13th
century that said there's a consensus on
not killing the civilians but they would
use a kind of consequentialist reasoning
by saying that actually they're killing
our civilians and so therefore we can
kill their civilians and they will quote
verses from the Quran effectively
alluding to the fact that it's a knife
or an
ey if you if you're going to receive
consequence so impose consequence the
way in which you receive the consequence
so they generalize the principle and
they say in fact what that means is if
they kill our civilians we can kill
their civilians and so they use an
emotional kind of argumentation and a
pragmatic kind of consequentialist
reasoning in order to get new recruits
now this is a concern it's a real
problem because it flies in the face of
sharia law it's not it's not normative
in any way shape or form but because of
the compelling nature of the emotional
aspect of this when a young man who's
not acquainted with the minay of Juris
Prudential um you know legalities in
Islamic law is presented with a picture
of some kid being blown up and then
being told actually there is some
Islamic justification it gives it does
actually give fuel adds fuel to the fire
of Islamic uh for example uh techism I
would call it and these groups become
more relevant so in other words there is
a threat here that the Muslim uh
population and the Western populations
have to be weary of and it is a threat
that some young men are going to be
looking at these things and thinking
well they're killing our civilians maybe
we have to go and kill theirs which is a
Mis notion in Islamic uh jurist Prudence
but why do we want that environment to
be uh to be acceptable or to be creating
a facilitation for that kind of
environment again and this is something
that the Western governments and Powers
have to look at because we don't want to
see young Muslim people in this country
or anywhere else being radicalized to
that
effect quite so uh and of course what's
true in Britain will
in terms of quantum be more true in
France uh there are nearly 10 million
Muslims in France uh in Belgium uh in in
Germany uh in North America even uh it
is uh just another Factor uh that we
have to put into this equation we are
losing any respect that we had in Muslim
countries I mean who if you run this
poll uh that I'm running tonight in
Muslim countries I mean the the result
would be laughable we're losing respect
and friends we've lost all the very good
friends we used to have in the Gulf in
Saudi Arabia and so on and we're also
placing our own Societies in danger all
to support
Netanyahu who is opposed to the outcome
that we claim that we support namely the
two-state solution make sense of that
for me
Muhammad absolutely and I think the
Americans know that full well which is
why we're seeing a change in parli what
if I had to guess I would think that the
conversation to put it in simplistic
terms between the Americans and the
Israelis at this point is listen we're
going to give you this amount of time
get the job done because if you can't
get the job done in this amount of time
the status quo cannot remain as it is it
will it will stabilize the region and
for the Americans I do really think that
their interests are slightly different
well at least to a large extent
completely different uh to the zist
interest in so much as that they have a
a region they want to protect uh they
have trade going through the region I
mean Yemen which is thei controlled
Yemen uh you have boats going over
carrying trade which can even easily be
pirated and stopped and these kind of
things massive disruption can take place
if heah gets involved if some escalation
takes place then they can start
destroying desalinization plants uh um
places and um other things in in Israel
itself they can start destroying the
natural gas uh reserves there there can
be things that take place if there's an
escalation which will ruin the economy
in that area which will have a trickle
down effect in in Europe and and the
Americans know that it's not just a
political and geopolitical issue it's an
economic issue and they don't want to
see uh this region being destabilized
because they have plans for that region
and so I do think that there is a
discussion that the Americans are having
with the Israelis that listen this is
that you've got to do this quickly
because public opinion is also against
us and and Biden's got his campaign that
he needs to do and he you know if you
look at the polls that have been done on
this
issue you'll find that this is not as
much a right left issue as it is a young
old issue that the ages 18 to 35 the
ones who are exposed to the social media
you know or have access to social media
and seeing all these people being killed
which are a key demographic for the for
the Democrats they they will less likely
especially definitely the Muslim
Community in America but certainly other
communities as well to vote for the
Democrats ever again if this continues
so there are so many things which make
this not worthwhile for the Americans
which I'm sure are being put into
consideration by them and so that's why
you're seeing a change in Parliament
with with some of Biden's words and I
think that that's the best way to
predict what's going to happen in the
future look at what's in the interest of
The Americans
uh and in this case we know in the
interest of the Americans stabilize the
region for trade purposes for
geopolitical purposes so that they can
have uh for for them they can have the
colonial Outpost which is Israel in in
in the region being protected because
they want to see the protection of
Israel as well of course that's that's
something Israel wants as well it's a
joint objective uh however this is
becoming too much now and I think in
about a month or two months time we're
going to see some serious
developments could be a lot of dead
people between now and then as always
Muhammad hijab you're a star player
thanks for coming on the mother of all
talk shows